- [Voiceover] What are
all the solutions to the
equation above?
And we have x plus
three, times x minus five
is equal to five.
You want to be very careful
here because you probably
have some experience with
algebra that, hey, once I factor
it out, maybe I could say,
okay, maybe this needs to be
equal to five, or this
needs to be equal to five.
That is not the way that it works.
That would not make
actually logical sense.
In order to, in order to kind
of make the factoring useful,
you have to be able to say,
hey, the product of these
two things is equal to zero
because if the product of
two things is equal to zero,
then you know that either one
or both of them need to be
equal to zero,
so we've actually have to do a
lot of algebraic manipulation
here to get it into that form
but let's see if we can do it.
So the first thing I would
do is just multiply out
x plus three, times x minus five,
so what's that going to be?
Well it's going to be x
times x, which is x squared
plus x times negative five,
so I could say that's minus five x,
plus three times x, so
that's plus three x,
plus three times negative
five, so it's minus 15,
and that's all going to be equal to,
that's all going to be equal to five,
and let's see what we can do from here.
We could say this is
going to be x squared,
and then these two terms right over here,
we can add together, negative
five x plus three x is
negative two x, and then we have
minus 15 is equal to five,
is equal to five.
And let's see, we can now
subtract five from both sides,
so you subtract five there,
you subtract five there,
and we're starting to
get to the home stretch,
and we would get x squared
minus two x, minus 20
is equal to zero.
So now we're in business.
Now we have this quadratic
in a form where we just
need to figure out what x
values are going to make this
expression equal to zero.
And the first temptation is to
see, well, can we, is there,
is there any way that we
can naturally factor this?
So is there a, let's see,
are there any two factors
of 20
that if I, and it's going to
be, one of them is going to be
positive and one's going to be negative,
since their product is, gets us negative,
or if I add them together
I get to negative two,
so let's see.
No, nothing jumps out.
You have four and five, two and 10.
Yeah, nothing's jumping out at me.
So, we can just resort to
the quadratic formula here.
When the quadratic formula
tells us that if I have
a x squared plus b x
plus c is equal to zero,
then the solutions of this
quadratic equation are going
to be x is equal to negative b
plus or minus the square root
of b squared minus four a
c, all of that over two...
all of that over two a.
Now I don't tell people
to memorize a lot in life,
but the quadratic formula
is one of those things
that it's not a bad idea to memorize,
but you should also watch the
Khan Academy videos on how
this proves and this comes just
naturally out of completing
the square on this thing right over here,
so also understand what
it's actually saying,
but it's also a good thing to know,
because just like that,
we can apply it to this,
so in this context, our a is one.
It's the coefficient out here
that's implicitly out there.
So a is one.
B is negative two.
B is equal to negative two.
That's this coefficient right over there,
and c is negative 20.
C is equal to negative 20,
so the roots are going to
be x is equal to negative b.
Well it's gonna be
negative of negative two,
so negative of negative two
is going to be positive two,
plus or minus the square root
of b squared, which is four,
minus four times a,
which is one,
times negative 20, so
instead I'll put a 20 here,
and since that's a negative
20, but I'm subtracting it,
I could put a plus there, and
then, all of that over two a.
Well a's just one.
All of that over two.
So it's gonna be two plus
or minus the square root of
four plus four times 20 is 80,
of 84 over, over two.
Now, already, if I'm under
time pressure, I already,
you know, see some choices
that are starting to
look a little bit like this,
but let's see if we can,
if we can, if we can get
to the right solution here.
So can I simplify this more?
Well, see the square root of 84,
84, that's going to be divisible by,
that's going to be divisible by four.
84 is, whoops,
84 is the same thing as four times 21,
and all that over two,
and this is going to be the same thing as,
I'll scroll down a little bit,
get a little bit more space,
This is going to,
x is going to be equal
to two plus or minus,
so this would be the same thing
as the square root of four
times the square root of 21,
which of course is two
all of that over two,
so if you divide each of these by two,
which we are doing right here,
it's gonna be one plus or
minus the square root of 21,
which is,
which is this choice right over there.
So it looked like a fairly
benign thing but we had to,
we had to multiply it out,
set it up, in kind of a form
where the quadratic formula would apply,
and we got a fairly,
a fairly hairy answer.